now we will have heidi jenkins
from the std
the program director for the scdtb
program at the department of public
health give us a little bit more of a
picture around other
sexually transmitted infections that are
affecting
men who have sex with men
good morning everybody
for those of you that have heard me
speak before you know this really comes
from the heart when i say what an honor
it is to be at an hiv conference talking
about other stds it truly is a pleasure
to be here today um
it's very important what's happening
with syphilis in connecticut and i'm
going to take a minute at the end to
mention a little bit about gonorrhea
also
it was interesting now we're at the the
through the first decade of the 2000 to
2009 era and i thought it was a perfect
time to look at what's happened with
syphilis i can sit and tell you the
stories but to look at the data really
brings up a whole different picture on
what we're seeing
looking at primary and secondary
syphilis if you've heard the talking
about a primary and secondary syphilis
are the two infectious stages of
syphilis and it's where we focus our
efforts in doing our epidemiological
interventions with clients who are
infected
so looking at primary and secondary
syphilis among msm
and others so our total case is reported
you see from 2000 to 2009 the greatest
increase has happened among msm's
there's very few cases reported among
any other
sexual heterosexual or females 97
percent of all the cases reported over
these 10 years are among males
and the increase again happening in the
msm community as opposed to other
populations
the increase if you look at 2000 there
were 12 cases of infectious syphilis
reported and in 2009 there were 65
that's a increase in over 300 percent
between 2000 to 2009
putting in another perspective in 1995
two percent of all our syphilis cases
were reported among msm
so of the msm what's the proportion that
are infected with hiv so this
graph here gives you the the different
um over the years of the cases that we
have had reported among msm the
percentage that were diagnosed as hiv
positive over the 10 years of syphilis
in connecticut uh 41 of all the cases
reported for primary and secondary
syphilis are co-infected with hiv
by age group
it's really been difficult for us with
age groups because one year it's younger
population the next year it's the 40
plus it varies there's no real trends
that we can have when we want to focus
our interventions on a particular age
group it's been very difficult for us
and you can see that from this with the
bars just up and down and up and down by
age groups
race ethnicity if this is a disease that
tends to be among
white males we have seen some increases
in african-american and hispanic but
again is that a trend difficult to say
because the numbers go up and down but
it's been pretty consistent among white
males over this epidemic since 2000
so looking at the numbers of this
primary and secondary syphilis from 2000
to 2009 80 percent of the cases reported
were among msm
we use this classification when we
interview someone with syphilis and the
question is when's the last time you had
sex with a man if they admit having sex
with a man they are considered an msm
they may be married they may be leading
their heterosexual life but they're
classified as an msm
of those
311 men 41 percent as i mentioned were
also diagnosed with hiv
we had nine percent of these infections
diagnosed more than once
since 2000 which means interventions are
not happening from our staff when we try
and talk about risk reduction if they're
in hiv care the interventions are not
happening either because these
individuals are continuing
to practice high-risk behaviors and
become reinfected again stds are a real
good marker for recent
unprotected sex recent transmission of
stds and hiv potentially so it really
lets us know what's happening in the
current when somebody's diagnosed with
an std
so looking at all early syphilis this
would be primary secondary early latent
anyone who's been diagnosed as having
syphilis for less than a year in the um
in connecticut 29
were diagnosed with hiv at the time they
were diagnosed with syphilis and 71
percent had previously been infected
with hiv when they were infected with
syphilis so when we interview them we
find out have you been hiv tested 71
were diagnosed with hiv prior to the
syphilis diagnosis
50 of msms are in their 30s and 40s we
tend to find this 30 plus again in a
given year you might have some younger
populations but we tend to find 30 plus
that are infected with primary and
secondary syphilis uh 26 of all the
cases were among african americans 17
among hispanics and you
i'm sure all know the population
percentages of these
african-american and hispanics in
connecticut
so what are the risk factors that we're
finding they meet sex partners on the
internet huge huge we've been told i can
have a man at my door quicker than a
pizza when i meet him on the internet
multiple partners these are individuals
that are having sex with many different
partners during the time that they could
be infected with syphilis and on top of
that the multiple internet partners
anonymous partners we earlier in this
the epidemic of this in the 2000s the
the big place to go to was the megaplex
in providence rhode island we were
getting all these people going there and
having sex in the megaplex and now it's
turned into adult bookstores we're not
getting people going to the megaplex
anymore adult bookstores in connecticut
is the hot spot for people to go and
have anonymous sex with multiple
partners
primary and secondary syphilis as i
mentioned is the highest priority for
our epidemiological follow-up
we are not very successful with our
epidemiological follow-up also partner
notification services one in the same
from 2005 to 2009 which is when we began
collecting this data 168 of 219 msms
with syphilis were interviewed we
interviewed 77
so we're missing a quarter of the
interviews because these guys don't want
to talk to us they don't like the state
they don't like us they want nothing to
do with us go away and never speak to me
again so we're not having a lot of
cooperation out there
so when we talk to them we'll say during
the time you had syphilis how many
partners whether you knew who they were
or not how many partners do you think
you had sex with
these 168 men admitted sex with over a
thousand partners
of those thousand partners we were able
to initiate to try and contact 171 less
than 20 percent of those named were we
able to contact
to attempt to get them in for testing
and treatment
we found 37 percent
located and treated
and of those 64
19 were infected with syphilis
so you're seeing these numbers 30
percent of what we're able to find are
infected with syphilis what about those
900 other people that we didn't find who
knows what's going on with that
and we found that there were 32
infections that were previously treated
so these were people that were named as
contacts to syphilis that had already
been treated for syphilis meaning to us
that potentially those previously
treated never told us about this partner
that we're now sitting here talking to
who's infected with syphilis
that is it for my slideshow with that
the one other thing i want to mention um
we're also doing some work with
gonorrhea because there is very recent
transmission when you talk about
gonorrhea syphilis could be within the
last year but we have recently done a
match on data from the gonorrhea
database with the
hiv surveillance database to match
gonorrhea cases with hiv co-infection
and we have found it from a four-year
period i think it was 2005 to 2008 there
were ten thousand cases of gonorrhea
reported and we found 145 people
infected with gonorrhea who were
infected with hiv so of those 116
matched once
11 matched twice
one match three times and one match four
times
there's some really really high risk
behavior going on out there it's not the
whole population there is a small group
that's practicing some very high risk
behavior
78 of these cases were male
about half were african-american about
half were msm
and 62 percent received their gonorrhea
diagnosis after they were infected with
hiv
about half the cases from hartford
bridgeport in new haven and that's
similar to what we're seeing with our
syphilis cases we can't be pointing
things at hartford bridgeport in new
haven anymore and any given year we have
cases reported from probably 30
different towns so those towns where
people are saying nobody has sex in my
town they are having sex in their town
so thank you very much